oh [__] it's [__] Wednesday strap on
to your seatbelts it's the [__] best
day your life since your dog got hit by
a car you understand me it don't get no
better than this the beautiful thing
about it it's all about you tonight
[__]
that's what I'm talking about
[__] uncle Joey here who the
[__] is this
paid your mere 546 in the morning crack
of dawn and now I'm yawning wiped the
coal from eyes see who's this paging me
and why
anyway uncle Joey here it's a beautiful
day to be alive the sun's shining the
birds are saying my ass was clean and
we're ready to go you understand me
tip-top Magoo I got the [__] leaving
of this dead star and Paris that star
this dish Navin [__] Fernanda smoked
and forgot to write the suicide note
that's how he got you understand me so
if you're thinking Ising yourself today
that star is the way to go
I know it's a little early but who gives
the Frenchman's [__] you know I'm saying
you got a walk on the wild side like
Marcel Marceau anyway
Wednesday the 19th 24 hours before 20
which for me is every [__] day at a
week now uncle Joey doesn't I got my
brand-new stick from the Arab everyone
so why he throws me feel these [__]
so lucky sticks to clean up my pipe and
I'm ready for the [__] that you
understand me got a podcast tonight
eight o'clock
I got jujitsu I got a meeting with the
hypnotist I gotta go see a man about a
dog at [__] three o'clock and that
said we're ready for the podcast and I
had a booth mushrooms explosives
whatever the [__] you need we got for
you tonight
but most importantly it's not what I got
it's what you got and when you're gonna
bring Taylor for a [__] table
today cuz you could talk all this [__]
you want but if you're gonna bring
something to the table today
you gotta justify your existence on a
[__] daily you understand me if not
it's not gonna work out for you you
gotta justify it might be Wednesday let
these little [__] Gentiles talk about
politics and whatever you you got your
[__] hand up Monalisa skirt with one
finger in there [__] and one finger
in a [__] nobody sees you coming and
that's the way you want it you
understand me
Larry believe me I was [__] show up
with a BMW I show up with a Chinese guy
in a rickshaw who's better than me
understand me anybody could have him
assay these beds who shows up with the
[__] little Chinese dude sweating his
feet off [__] up I got him on the 405
running up the [__] HOV Lane that's
how uncle Joey does it you follow me
let's try out this [__] dead star to
make sure all my cylinders are in
checked is that's the most important and
every day you gotta have a checklist
mind check protein powder check you know
I wrote that my goals check I got my
head I know exactly where I want to go
to lay and where I'm gonna [__] take
this you understand me
you gotta see yourself taking it to the
next [__] level regardless of what
they're telling you that time you can't
do it or you think you can't do it who
gives a [__] it's in the [__] juice
to succeed is in your nut sack I'm
saying you gotta you can't let your
people down you got people around you
they love you if you don't want to do it
for you do it for them that's what I
don't give a [__] about me but I wanted
to make my friends proud of me
they helped me out when I was in a bind
why help me out in the vein with Joey
what's with the chitty-chat him in the
[__] sermon let's spark this meal
hell yeah
it's Wednesday I got one foot in the
grave want a banana peel and so do you
you don't say you could be looking at
your [__] chit chat phone and next
thing you know you get hit by a [__]
car
this could be it so by the time you
leave the door the first foot the first
step outside the door in your mind
you're going I'm going for broke today
[__] it I might get hit by a meteor by
the Koreans so whatever I do I'm
slinging dick with both hands remember
they suck you dick today
well it'll suck you dick tomorrow but
somewhere along the line they're gonna
suck your dick if you stay focused I
mean this reefer is on a roll today
I suggest you draw with a perennial get
yourself a little dead star tell them to
throw in the [__] whoo this side
whatever the [__] it is I can't remember
right now you know I'm saying I'm like
three Bulls in Paris oh gee what do you
think you call it Paris because every
time you smoke it you think you get shot
you follow me I got that guy who gives a
[__]
Easter's over I can be myself again
anyway this is how we're doing idiot la
Wednesday we're doing it big 9 39 40 in
the one who gives a [__] I've been out
here since 6:15 this morning trying to
write my jokes just ain't working no
more my jokes just ain't working don't
what I'm [__] believable I gotta get
my [__] together I'm the right and right
I can't put nothing together but this is
what happens to this what happens you
gotta hang in there I know I'm slipping
lately but don't matter because I know
the [__] clouds are gonna part to
show the true color of the skies and
there's uncle Joey swinging dick with a
kite with a wig like Ben Franklin
we dick should we do one more to [__]
call it complete who does to [__]
both [__] these [__] guys they're
probably lying next move this pineapple
Express oh my god is such a body hi what
the [__] are you talking about what the
[__] are you talking about body hi who
taught you who do you hang out with
it's a good joint had a filter and
everything well that's your problem
right there that's your [__] problem
right there too much I Time magazine and
you hang out with too many [__] habit
was okay you see uncle Joey showing up
here with black dudes with dreads or
white dudes with tattoos uncle Joey's a
lone wolf [__] that's how I do my best
work understand me you gotta be a lone
wolf you gotta have friends but you
gotta be a lone wolf so there's no
misunderstanding
there you go Hey
all right the lung is [__] tremendous
like I said it's all about you today
[__] the outside forces [__] the
resistance [__] what you can't do
[__] me you're not supposed to do it's
your world [__] even jumping it with
two feet or hang yourself like Aaron
Hernandez plain and [__] simple
Wednesday the 19th of April my ears are
still [__] up I don't give a [__] I'll
see you guys tonight
eight o'clock and don't make me tell you
again tomorrow night 4:20 the show's
almost sold out 11 live Oxnard
not to mention two shows Friday to show
sadly don't [__] around don't [__]
around let's get down it's a beach
community it's California back the
[__] car let's smoke the [__] dope
you're next to Santa Barbara there's a
joint that's got lasagna with a meatball
in the middle in the stem [__] it nice
Ventura Oxnard I'm gonna get a little
hotel room go out there and see somebody
get bit by a shark
don't worry about I bring my own toilet
anyway I love you talk suckers stay
black have a good day
look behind you're looking funny and
look for the side to you meow
oh yeah and cry out don't say a [__]
word you don't know nothing eight
o'clock tonight I see you on YouTube
uncle Joey beer stay back